من القاهره ينورنا المطرب الشعبي عصام
شعبان عبد الرحيم اهلا بك يا عصام منورنا
في صباح العربيه هلا بهالطله شكرا على
تواجدك معانا
طيب
عبر الفيسبوك في صوره تجمعك مع محمد عن
عمل مشترك واغنيه دويتو مشتركه بينكم
حدثنا بالاول عن هذه الاعلان
[موسيقى]
المكتب
وقعدنا نتكلم مع بعض
حسيت ان هو ينفع يعني ايه
اصل هو انا بصراحه ربنا لقيته يعني شفت
الصوره بتاعه النجم
مشهور زي سوره النجم بس انا مش عارف يبقى
نجم في ايه
فقلت انا اجربه انا اللي اجربه في الغنى
جربته ينفع يغني اااه يعني على قده في
الموضوع بس هيجيء منه يعني
[موسيقى]
تحول تتعاون معه او تعمل معه اغنيه حتى
تلحق او تستفيد بالتراند
بعد اذن حضرتك وبعد اذن كل الناس انا مش
محتاج محمد عشان اطلع تريند عليه انا البس
وابقى شكل ابويا كده اطلع تريند انا ابن
شعبان عبد الرحيم واي وقت هالبس هدوم
الجزمه والحزام والبنطلون والساعتين
والحاجات هبقى ترند في ساعتها انا مش
محتاجه اطلع التريند على محمد انا محتاج
اما لقيت محمد لقيته غلبان قلت سبحان الله
الدارجه دي كلها لو بتتعمل بفلوس كان
زمانك كلفت 20 مليون جنيه
الدقه بتاعه محمد دي لو بتعمل فلوس كانت
رقم كبير قوي
في ناس كثير قوي بتوع المهرجانات دول
مشهورين قوي وما بيعرفوش يغنون
بدعم المفرط لمحمد عامل النظافه كيف ترد
على ذلك
[موسيقى]
ده غريز ربنا بعته له
ده رزقي ربنا بعثهوله عشان يطلع من يطلع
من الموضوع اللي هو فيه ده
ومن اللي هو ما لوش فلوس وكفران وتعبان
ربنا بعدله الرزق ده عشان يطلع مننا
ويكرمه ربنا في حته ثانيه تبع الغناء او
تبع التمثيل
هو ما فيش حاجه انا فاتتني الصوت وانا
بقول لك
انا انا عامل له كلمتين هيقولهم في الغنوه
يمكن يضرب وينجح ما تضمنيش
زي بقيه الموجودين في السوق والله العظيم
اصوات وحشه قوي قوي
ينجح مع محمد بالغناء
بامر الله ينجح انا انا نيتي من جوه سليمه
وهو غلبان والدنيا هتمشي على كده وخلاص
عن الاغنيه اسمها ايه تفاصيل اكثر لصباح
العربيه على الاغنيه
اسمها
احنا اولاد تسعه
كلنا اولاد تسعه
واخذه بالك
امل
احنا اولاد تسعه دي انا بغنيها ومحمد
هيبقى واقف موت بدل المودلز عارفه البنت
المودلز اللي في الكلي
طيب عصام
مين مين دي اللي هتغني محمد فيها
اللي انا هاقولها دي بتاعه سانكيو اللي
محمد اغاني فيها
[موسيقى]
دادا بس خلاص عشان ما تحرقش الغيره
اوجه رساله لمحمد ان شاء الله باذن الله
ان شاء الله باذن الله ربنا يكرمك واول ما
تنجح في الغناء او في التمثيل
تفضل متواضع وتفضل كويس وتقابل الناس وترد
الناس وتلاقي كله يعني تلاقي واحد لو
قابلت واحد زيك كده في الايام اللي انت
فيها دلوقتي لو قابلت واحد زيك تعبان
توقف جنبه وتساعده لحد ما ربنا يكرمه
وينجح الله يوفقكم شكرا جزيلا
مع الناس
واحد ينفع يتزق في اي حاجه يزقه واحد عايز
يتجوز واحد عايز مش عارف ايه كده يعني
الله يرحمه
ممكن استاذنك عن اذنك
الجمهور قناه العربيه نقرا الفاتحه لابويا
بعد اذنك
شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره المطرب الشعبي
عصام شعبان عبد الرحيم شكرا جزيلا